[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radio Francia internacional
con el aniversario el 40 aniversario de
las emisiones de recién español para
toda América Latina y por ello nos
preguntamos en una edición especial que
importancia tiene un medio internacional
en estos momentos en los tiempos de los
de gente como es lo más dominando
Twitter o de la generación tiktok o del
proyecto metaverso de Zuckerberg nos lo
preguntamos con Mauricio latorre jefe
del servicio en español de recibir
bienvenido Mauricio Gracias Carlos el
dato masini consultora de medios
especialista en nuevas tecnologías
bienvenida Elda Muchas gracias y
Francisco alve doctorando en la
universidad París 8 y profesor en la
universidad or de Uruguay va a ser muy
interesante para que nos explique
También la historia y como han
evolucionado los medios de comunicación
bienvenido Muchas gracias la importancia
y la evolución de los medios
internacionales a partir del 40
aniversario de radio Francia
internacional para toda América Latina
hoy nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
y París radio Francia internacional van
a escuchar ustedes nuestro programa para
América Latina emitiendo diariamente
desde las 22 hasta las 2 de la madrugada
están escuchando una de las primeras
emisiones de recí fue bajo la
presidencia de françois mitagana ya por
1982 Cuando rc comenzó a emitir para
toda América Latina un momento en el que
había muchas dictaduras aún en la región
y de ahí la importancia de abrir una
oferta independiente desde entonces han
pasado 40 años cargados de cambios en el
mundo de la comunicación o nos
preguntamos por el sentido de un medio
internacional en 2022 40 años después
los autoritarismos a los que se enfrenta
la información independiente no son los
mismos en la mayoría de casos tienen
otras caras y el consumo de dicha
información también es muy distinto y
todo ello en este contexto mundial de
los tecnofeudalismos encarnados en
figuras como es lo más o Mark Zuckerberg
y cuando más voces críticas se alzan
para cuestionar sus modelos tanto meta
el nuevo Twitter que nos da noticias
casi cada día repasemos algunas portadas
que nos deja este asunto diario
Liberación se pregunta en esta portada
si el modelo de Mask ha cocido o ha
dejado chamuscado a Twitter anunciantes
y abonados cuestionan el nuevo modelo el
QR internacional dedicó una portada esos
millonarios de la Tec a los
tecnofeudalistas como Mask dice el
rotativo que la prensa estadounidense se
inquieta por el fenómeno la revista
francesa Franco dedica esta portada a
Rusia today la televisión exterior rusa
a la que define como tele Putin muestra
de que un medio internacional también
puede carecer de Independencia la
revista especializada Newman report de
la Universidad de Harvard dice que nada
nuevo bajo el sol la tecnología dice
está cambiando los medios como he hecho
siempre desde Gutenberg hasta las nuevas
tecnologías de hoy en día bueno señor la
torre 40 años de refi en 2022 son los
mismos los objetivos que en 1982 En qué
se parecen y en qué se distinguen bueno
con nosotros nacimos como redacción en
para América Latina como decía será la
época de las dictaduras en América
Latina y había todo un sentido de de
dirigir nuestras emisiones para para
para esa zona justamente porque hay un
problema de libertad de expresión y de
Derechos Humanos que son un poco las
líneas también de radiofrecuencia
internacional que es un poco defender
los derechos humanos y la libertad de
expresión ahora obviamente las cosas han
cambiado mucho no hay no hay el mismo
tipo de dictaduras hay algunos países
donde todavía hay problemas como puede
ser en Cuba como puede ser problemas de
censura en Nicaragua O sea que todavía
sigue teniendo hay un interés pero sobre
todo hay un interés para llegar con
noticias y información internacionales
en un continente que muchas veces tiene
algunas falencias en cuanto a la
cobertura de las de las noticias
internacionales y en una época donde
como os hablabas de las redes sociales y
de polarizaciones y de aumento de los
extremismos desde los años de Trump
sonaro la posición de las radios
internacionales en todo caso una como
radio Francia internacional es llegar
con un tipo de información digamos lo
más Imparcial posible para que la gente
pueda hacer su propia opinión eso es un
poco básicamente el interés que tienen
hoy las radios internacionales
de comunicación son sin duda un Pilar
para el desarrollo de cualquier
democracia si pudiéramos trazar en tres
o cuatro pinceladas las principales
características de un medio
internacional hoy en día en el panorama
Cuál es cuál serían en él los medios
internacionales son muy importantes hoy
porque justamente en muchos países el
consumo de cada medio están bueno como
bien explicaba
mezclado de alguna manera con las
ideologías y con los problemas de cada
país entonces para las audiencias es muy
importante contar con un medio
internacional para recibir información
mucho más clara Bueno más objetiva no
entre comillas y poder sacar eh sus
propias conclusiones sobre un panorama
internacional la pandemia también y
fenómenos o la guerra que como está
pasando hoy de Ucrania son fenómenos que
impactan en todo el mundo y Bueno es muy
positivo que existan ese tipo de medios
para informarse señores decíamos antes
viviendo unas portadas la tecnología
está cambiando los medios como ha hecho
siempre decía la universidad de Harvard
claro cuando llegó la tele se ve lo que
viene a decir nada nuevo bajo el sol
cuando llego a la tele muchos decían que
la radio acabar cuando llegó Pero al
final todos han ido Sobreviviendo y se
han ido reacoplando a nuevos tipos de
consumo No sí es un poco también la
postura no de mccluhan no en esta idea
de ver los cambios y entender cómo las
nuevas tecnologías afectan nuestra
manera de percibir el mundo pero
justamente no cuando también hubo este
tema de que el libro estaba muriendo
cuando apareció el kínder y bueno el
libro sigue existiendo y sigue
existiendo el Kindle con algunos
problemas pero sigue ahí entonces me
parece que que justamente lo que tenemos
que hacer es no tal vez ser menos
moralistas o juzgar menos Y tratar de
aprender y ver cómo cómo estos cambios
en las tecnologías nos afectan y afectan
nuestra forma
primero y de las redes sociales ahora y
sin embargo el mayor cambio que han
vivido en la coplo de los medios de
comunicación a la sociedad actual Elda
yo creo que nunca un medio mató a otro
hoy tenemos nuevos soportes y nuevas
formas de contar un poco lo mismo el
fenómeno de los podcast refiriéndonos a
la radio es un poco lo que se empezó en
la radio como el radioteatro en su
momento no no se van adaptando la forma
si el rey sigue haciendo el contenido
por supuesto la llegada de internet
modificó y transformó digitalmente todos
los medios y todos los medios
tradicionales también se tuvieron que
adaptar a difundir sus contenidos
principalmente en las redes sociales
Mauricio precisamente esa transición
tecnológica también la ha vivido durante
40 años al principio siendo una radio
vamos a llamarlo pura más o menos y
ahora no tanto la hibri con internet
ahora con la imagen es también parte de
la actualidad no de esa evolución de
recí sí la evolución natural nosotros
comenzamos en el 82 con las ondas cortas
o sea lo único que había era ondas
cortas después se evoluciona la década
siguiente con el satélite después y de
cada siguiente con internet y el
streaming que permite llegar a todas
partes nosotros además tenemos un método
de difusión que es a través de unas una
red de unas 700 radios asociadas en todo
el continente americano que nos retoman
con una fidelidad digamos una calidad de
alta fidelidad sea por satélite o sea
por por el streaming y internet también
Bueno nos hizo llevar a ampliar toda la
la nos da la ventaja digamos de llegar a
más y más gente que es nuestro Nuestro
objetivo principal es llegar con
nuestras informaciones a la mayor
cantidad de gente posible a través de
muchas otras plataformas como son las
redes sociales como es y como es
france24 que también estamos
transmitiendo por televisión este este
programa y obviamente todo lo que es
internet y las redes sociales
nos dirigimos a varios eléctricos y una
de las obsesiones y lo Confieso que
tenemos los medios de comunicación no
seamos los tradicionales es que nos vea
la gente joven que un joven un
adolescente se siente delante de un
noticiero televisivo de un noticiero de
Radio Pero cuesta cuesta traer ese
público joven Cómo debe dirigir los
mensajes los medios de comunicación
tradicionales a ese público joven Bueno
lo principal es pensar una estrategia
digital diferencial para cada tipo de
audiencia no que no quiere decir cambiar
el contenido del programa sino cómo nos
acercamos con ese primer mensaje tenemos
que tener en cuenta que el 90% de las
personas que consumen hoy medios lo
hacen a través del Smartphone no el 90%
de las últimas diferentes estudios no
voy a mencionar uno pero en la mayoría
coinciden en que la gente consume medios
a través de las redes sociales o de lo
que ve en su teléfono entonces es muy
importante Cómo anunciamos eso Por
supuesto contenido de calidad que sean
didácticos que sean atractivos sin que
pierdan calidad y rigor en la en la
información pero bueno Ese es el desafío
del periodista que sigue teniendo y del
comunicador y de los medios y los que
hacemos esto que bueno es encontrar el
mensaje no el mensaje para cada
audiencia no es fácil eh Claro pero no
sé rejuvenecer la audiencia significa
hacer menos ortodoxo por ejemplo un
informativo señor Albert o que baje en
profundidad es informativo porque
estamos en la sociedad del clic del
consumo rápido de las nuevas tecnologías
en las redes Bueno yo creo que en
realidad lo que una de las también unas
alternativas es incluir gente joven en
los procesos y no solamente como
conductores o lo que sea sino también
siendo los que escriben las
informaciones los que están en el
proceso como productores etcétera que
ayuda también a a poder crear contenido
desde lo que a ellos les interesa
Entonces no solamente es pensar en ellos
como consumidores sino también como
productores de noticias y contenidos
Francisco súper interesante porque el
ritmo de la edición el ritmo de cómo se
consume de las noticias también es muy
importante no el ritmo de la atención
que tiene los consumidores porque todo
va más rápido Entonces ahora tenemos que
contar las noticias quizás de otra
manera pero es lo que dice hacerlos
parte también de bueno son parte de
obviamente ya pero bueno darle más
espacio para y confianza en la creación
de contenidos y e innovar no para
innovar
el problema de los formatos el problema
y el desafío de los formatos porque el
hecho de Buscar siempre los formatos
cortos que son los que más consumen los
los chicos los jóvenes ahora en
instagram o en tiktok que son formatos
de un minuto máximo donde si se pueden
hacer bien es son geniales en el sentido
de si hay un buen mensaje pero hay que
tener en cuenta que el formato corto
también habría que saber cuál es la
consecuencia simplemente informarse
sistemáticamente con formatos cortos yo
creo que siempre hay que tratar de
buscar un poco el fondo con formatos un
poco más largos y no acostumbrar a las
nuevas generaciones solamente a formatos
micros igual hay algunas buenas
experiencias que
le entrevistas en profundidad como de
varios programas en la Argentina o de
caja bueno de varios formatos donde las
entrevistas largas por ahí de tres horas
en YouTube se consumen no entonces
también hay que pensar
gente joven No consume la profundidad
Bueno hay algún un sector que sí otro
que no pero también pero la edad no lo
determina no lo determina no lo
determina también pasan un montón de
tiempo consumiendo noticias en Twitch y
también personas más grandes también
empiezan a hacerlo entonces digo no no
es una cosa es obviamente generacional
pero hay que Probar con nuevos formatos
y me parece que la clave es lo que decía
Francisco de incorporarlos a la
producción de contenido que es
totalmente nueva en cualquier caso la
veracidad y el pluralismo es lo que
deben diferenciar un medio de una red
social entendemos No pues señor Álvarez
Sí estoy de acuerdo con que lo
importante Ahí es incluir varias voces y
también en el sentido la importancia de
un medio como este que es en español de
crear una comunidad de español porque en
realidad en cada país tenemos bueno los
medios argentinos tienen gente
argentinos veo pues paraguayos en hechos
por paraguayos etcétera entonces es
interesante un medio Así que sea
internacional porque también crea como
esta idea de comunidad español donde hay
varias voces distintas de distintos
lados distintos contextos que hablan y
que interactúan con sus con lo que
intentamos por supuesto cada día en r-fi
me van a permitir una pequeña pausa y
enseguida estamos de vuelta aquí en
Primera Plana Gracias
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana este a la
semana a partir del 40 aniversario de
las emisiones de refri para toda América
Latina nos preguntamos la importancia de
un medio de comunicación internacional
en este mundo de la generación del
tiktok y de los Tecno feudalistas como
elon musk no lo hacemos con Mauricio
latorre jefe del servicio en español de
reciel la tomasini consultora en medios
especialista en nuevas tecnologías y
Francisco Alves doctorante en París ocho
y profesor en la universidad or de
Uruguay las redes sociales han
modificado sin duda nuestra forma de
consumir información la generación de
fake news pero también la inmediatez el
poder dar un giro de también dar un
grito de alarma ante una catástrofe es
decir entendemos que no se puede ser
maniquí a la hora de Establecer un
juicio de valor en cuanto a que una red
social pueda ser de por sí positivo al
negativa no
no hay Bueno hay diferentes visiones
nosotros bueno conversamos acá de la
importancia de la democracia y la
libertad de expresión y en eso las redes
han sido las redes sociales son muy
positivas ahora veíamos justo lo que
está pasando con Twitter con el lo más
que hay cambios en la red que bueno
quien puede decir yo soy un usuario
verificado entonces lo que yo digo Bueno
tiene cierto trabajo y cierto chequeo de
información Bueno es muy importante que
ahora y como siempre los medios estén y
ahora le parece un signo de oficial
entonces sabemos que estamos consumiendo
esa información y que pertenece a ese
medio Pero bueno también lo que pasa
siempre en las redes sociales se generan
noticias falsas se difunde muy
rápidamente Pero bueno siguen teniendo
el impacto
a preguntarle por la actualidad
lógicamente por ello más porque tenemos
con el nuevo modelo de Twitter que así
actualidad cada día ahora de bandada de
trabajadores y cuál es la visión que
tiene un Tecno feudalista como le llamo
al principio como es lo másk de algo
como Twitter porque hay que nos despista
todos
Bueno en principio
lo que él quería hacer con la red era
bueno
algunos cambios en relación a cómo se
difundían los contenidos en la red que
no sean cronológicos que la gente tenga
más opciones para ver cómo quiere leer
esos contenidos consumirlos y en eso me
parece que siempre es positivo lo que
está pasando a nivel empresarial bueno
son disputas que viene teniendo con los
trabajadores y yo creo que en este
momento que recién viene a Bueno a poner
un poco de su orden o su visión en la
empresa está teniendo ciertas
resistencias a alguno de los cambios que
quiere hacer y bueno veremos qué pasa
implementaron un cambio que era que
cualquier usuario pagando 8 dólares o
bueno depende el país donde estaba podía
decir yo soy un usuario verificado pero
no funcionó porque un montón de personas
desean ser alguien que no era y también
se las verificaba entonces bueno viene
por ahora a prueba y error veremos qué
pasa
veremos qué pasa bueno y tiene mucho que
ver con el poder de lo que estamos
hablando en las relaciones de los medios
con el poder político Siempre han sido
Siempre han existido en realidad esta
pregunta nos la han formulado un montón
de veces pero hay veces que la tenemos
que responder porque quizás nuestro
deber Mauricio Cómo es la relación entre
Franz mediamoner con el grupo mediático
exterior francés y el poder político en
Francia si efectivamente se la gran
curiosidad visto siempre de América
Latina porque en América Latina en
general se asocia lo que es un medio
Público con el un medio de estado es
decir el medio público las radios
nacionales por ejemplo cambia de
gobierno y cambio de dirección entonces
y responden a a lo que dice a la línea
del nuevo gobierno aquí es completamente
diferente o sea bueno sí en la época de
de golf por supuesto era lo mismo pero
después de los años 80 para acá hay una
Independencia total entre el el gobierno
de turno y el todo el Polo público no
solamente nuestro grupo rfi fans 24 pero
también la la radio y la televisión
pública tienen cada uno directores
generales que que son designados por un
ente autónomo que no depende del Eliseo
entonces hay una separación total
incluso hay muchos medios que son
opositores o sea medios públicos si
tomamos Francia por ejemplo es es la
radio más escuchada de la mañana y tiene
una una bueno toda una sensibilidad de
izquierda y son críticos del gobierno
bueno suscriptores diversificar
publicidad métodos de financiación los
medios sin duda buscan su sostenibilidad
en este panorama complejo Que hoy
estamos describiendo no sé si señor no
hemos hecho sobre la suficiente
pedagogía para explicar que la
información se paga que no puede ser
gratuita que hay que subvencionarla
pagarla o financiarla de alguna forma es
importante hacer ese tipo de pedagogía
ante el público no es complicado porque
por supuesto que la gente está dispuesta
a veces a pagar No sé cualquier cosa
pero un diario no sí el valor que tiene
esto no es muy difícil me parece Porque
desde el principio se hizo mal en el
sentido de que es difícil que alguien
que obtuvo algo gratis toda su vida de
repente empieza a pagarlo como lo que
pasó con YouTube no que tiene por
ejemplo no sé leía como un varios
millones de suscriptos pagos Premium
pero tiene billones de de suscriptos que
no pagan entonces hay una gran grandes
balance En ese sentido y creo que que sí
que hay que hacerlo y también empezar a
que eso tenga una visión en lo que se le
paga los periodistas también no
solamente
lo que se cobra para el exterior sino
también como que el periodismo es un
trabajo bien pago bien remunerado para
que se puedan hacer trabajos de calidad
y de y con cierta profundidad hablaba
antes del contexto actual con los
tecnoceudalistas pero también tenemos
que hablar de la pandemia no sé si creen
que la pandemia marcó un punto de
inflexión para los medios de
comunicación tanto en su consumo como un
nivel interno en el tratamiento
Informativo en la llamada Buscar
expertos qué les pareció ese punto de la
pandemia en cuanto a los medios de
comunicación
pero sí que sí fue fue un periodo
bastante No sé como
definirlos y revolucionarios crítico en
el que nos encontramos todos los medios
en una situación primero para nuestra
propia producción de noticias que
teníamos que hacerlo desde la casa hacer
radio desde la casa es una cosa
revolucionario y logramos hacerlo y la
otra es encontrar un montón de expertos
que nos expliquen el porqué del Cómo de
que lo básico de lo que está ocurriendo
y que muchas veces tener un cuidado de
no caer con los falsos expertos que nos
que no que en lugar de aclarar las cosas
nos las compliquen yo pienso sí que fue
bastante revolucionario en el sentido de
una toma de conciencia además también
Creo que está dentro de las líneas
editoriales de los medios hay una toma
de conciencia de la ecología Es sobre
todo con creo que nos dimos cuenta de
que se contaminaba menos produciendo
menos y que hay ahora con la cop 27 se
está hablando mucho pero hay una digamos
una toma de conciencia en los medios
sobre todo aquí en Francia de la
necesidad de justamente devolucionar
hacer evolucionar la actualidad con
desde un prisma
ecológico de impacto ecológico de las
cosas que decimos las decisiones
políticas las decisiones económicas
Quizá lo más característico de esta
sociedad sea hoy por hoy la celeridad la
rapidez con la que consumimos
información no sé el medio es parte de
esta realidad o debe luchar por crear
espacios a contracorrientes es decir
Buscar espacios de reposo hacer una
especie de contrarrevolución respecto al
momento actual
Yo creo que si los medios no se adaptan
a lo que la sociedad
no es que la verdad es que los medios
también se deben a sus audiencias
quieren difundir lo que hacen entonces
Tienen también que adaptarse a eso sí es
verdad que hay algunos fenómenos que se
vienen escuchando de personas que están
haciendo como lo que decía cierta
conciencia de detox informativo también
hay
algunos estudios muestran que las
audiencias más jóvenes también dicen
bueno consumo menos información sobre
política menos información sobre esto
porque me estresa porque me genera
ansiedad y Estos son pequeños pequeños
no grandes nuevos problemas que trae
este consumo acelerado de información no
solo quiero decir de programas de
noticias digo en general de lo de las
redes los que venimos hablando que
genera muchísima ansiedad y bueno estos
son los nuevos también trastornos
este asunto Bueno pero claro exactamente
Entonces vamos hacia ahí a ver qué qué
qué trae esto que nos depara en general
y a futuro y esto se refleja hasta en
los géneros periodísticos porque parece
señor Alves que en la sociedad líquida
la entrevista en profundidad es casi
alternativa los que hacen Sí en realidad
justamente se trata también de buscar y
adaptar el estilo que uno escribe que
uno conducen una entrevista o lo que sea
a los medios como decía Elda Hoy hay
entrevistas en YouTube de tres horas que
mira todo el mundo hay substag que son
larguísimos con newsletter extensas que
la gente Lee es decir la gente está
leyendo y largo y está mirando cosas
largas pero tal vez no en el formato que
lo hizo siempre
hay una algo nuevo que me parece
interesante los podcast duran muchísimo
y la gente los Escucha lo que me parece
que se van adaptando al multi tag que no
como Bueno ahora las noticias y vemos en
los diarios viene la opción de escuchar
la noticia vieron que está el artículo
el artículo de la web y también ahora la
puedes escuchar y eso aquí me parece que
es como un signo de la época donde Bueno
lo puedes escuchar mientras haces otra
cosa no entonces también es cómo vivimos
todo el tiempo tenemos que producir Y
eso la moviendo la radio Exacto el radio
estamos viva que nunca o sea Pero bueno
Cómo se fue adaptando distintos soportes
y celeridad
la Guerra de Ucrania parece que entramos
en un mundo a golpe de crisis sucesivas
Qué papel juega Mauricio medio
internacional en este mundo de crisis
sucesivas y sobre todo Mirando al futuro
como como ve el futuro de refi En cual A
lo mejor si digo en 40 años no sé me
estoy pasando y exagerando Pero bueno 40
no sé si existe tenemos acá nosotros no
creo este no Yo pienso que la radio
tiene un gran futuro como decíamos al
principio la televisión no la mató en la
radio tiene una capacidad de una
facilidad tecnológica para llegar a los
oídos una facilidad de escucha en el
sentido que no necesita la dependencia
frente a la frente a la pantalla uno
puede estar corriendo haciendo plugin y
escuchando y escuchando radio eso no yo
creo que es es irremplazable y Incluso
en materia tecnológica y novedades que
están que van a llegar que son por
ejemplo las ondas cortas como las que
nosotros habíamos empezado pero están
las ondas cortas digitales que van a
volver a que van a volver y que son
súper útiles por redonda corta permite
atravesar fronteras
en los países donde no podemos llegar
porque hay censura en las ondas cortas
digitales podrían otra vez relanzar
relanzar La potencia de las radios de
que depende entonces él la Francisco de
que un medio se proyecte en el futuro
donde habría que buscar las claves para
ser sostenible para Bueno es un cambio
en el modelo de negocio es clave por
todo lo que venimos hablando Francisco
opinar del tema pero justamente las
suscripciones fue siempre algo que
siempre para mí existió digo antes uno
se suscribía lo recibían en papel en su
casa o ibas al kiosco y lo pagabas digo
la gente digo está acostumbrado para eso
diciendo a pagar por la información creo
que lo que cambió es el método de cómo
de cómo lo tiene que pagar y como Bueno
lo que está en internet no es gratis que
no es lo mismo que el medio de
comunicación lo que está en internet es
gratis nos cuesta más pero los niveles
en Consumo de América Latina y de los
principales economías del mundo más o
menos tienen los mismos niveles de pago
de medios Francisco última frase última
idea simplemente que justamente pensando
en esto en Uruguay colaboro con un
diario que funciona Prácticamente solo
con suscripciones y ya tiene muchos años
y tiene una trayectoria En eso yo creo
que que lo que hay que hacer es producir
contenidos que llaman la atención que
que un diferencial que diga Bueno compro
esto porque esto me da algo que no me
dan los otros o que no me da Twitter o
que no me da internet gratis no entonces
tener algo que sea específico de un
medio Bueno pues os quedamos con estoy
esperanza y esperanza en el Horizonte en
el horizonte de este 40 aniversario de
refi que hoy hemos celebrado en nuestra
manera con esta emisión La Primera Plana
Muchísimas gracias a los tres y a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana Muchas
gracias
[Música]